In Russia, President Vladimir Putin and Turkish President Tayyip Erdogan...
...both said they hoped to resolve positively "complicated issues in the region,"...
...as they met in Sochi.
In Chile, the government said 15 people have been killed...
...in five days of rioting, arson and violent clashes...
...that have almost paralyzed the South American country.
Protesters in Lebanon kept the country on lockdown...
...as they gathered for a sixth consecutive day, demanding new leaders...
...despite the government's adoption of an emergency economic rescue plan.
In Canada, Prime Minister Justin Trudeau claimed victory early Tuesday morning...
...after winning a second term in the nation's general election.
Finally from Israel, the country was bracing for weeks of continued political uncertainty...
...after Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu failed to form a coalition government,...
...with the task expected to be passed on to his main challenger, Benny Gantz, this week.